Cap Canaveral en Floride, vous avez déjà entendu le
nom auparavant, soyez notre invité alors que nous
vous montrons ce que le ministère de la Défense nous montre alors
que nous rejoignons les journalistes pour cette première
visite guidée, nous montons au sommet d'une
grue à portique de 145 pieds afin que les nouvelles du jour
caméra  peut obtenir un panorama à vol d'oiseau
du cadre des lancements récents de l'Oncle Sam
de ses deux bébés lunes et
peut-être plus pour suivre les Jupiter et les
atlas les reniflements de Thor Walmart et
le nouveau Titan, tous avec leurs propres
rampes de lancement, seul un caméraman pourrait
pleinement apprécier comment  inhabituel car cette
opportunité d'obtenir ses propres gros plans à
Canaveral des films militaires officiels sont
généralement distribués par exemple pour montrer
comment ils alimentent une avant-garde pour prendre son
montant de satellite
pendant que nous visitons ensuite le blockhaus de l'Atlas
et voyons le système de surveillance une
annonce dramatique  du commandant de Canaveral
, le général de division Yates, nous pouvons
battre les Russes en envoyant une fusée sur
la lune, dit-il, et une victoire américaine majeure
ce serait dans l'important
rythme technologique et psychologique